new technology at mccarran making some
big changes that impact how we get
through tsa lines victoria saha joins us
live to show us what we need to know
before we fly victoria
the incoming passengers here behind me
will have to go through some new changes
the next time they fly out they will
only be required to present their id at
security
[Music]
all security checkpoints will have
credential authentication technology
also known as cat impacting every
traveler flying out of mccarran this
will allow tsa to scan your photo id and
confirm your flight without you having
to hand over your boarding pass
lori dankers with the tsa says this will
help add an extra layer of security to
confirm each passenger is authorized to
fly we need to know
the person who is flying is who they say
they are that they are not an imposter
in any way so the cat unit is able to
detect that mccarran is one of the few
airports across the country with this
technology and hopes to prevent fake
travel documents